what's happening there reject nation
what's going on
aaron or as i call him around here black
greg
i am black greg it's a it's a mask
because it's a mask like you know master
of disguise i i'm
you or would you be underneath the mask
right now blacker
or more like me i would
masquerade i would be blacker and sadder
ah yeah that sounds like black greg
invisible episode threes we're gonna
watch today subscribe and click that
notification bell you get notified when
our next invincible reaction is up hit
that like button
um what else do i say oh yeah full
length watch along is it over where
patreon that's right we got a bunch of
other shows that we cover
at the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch along
included
these two that thing where you list all
the shows no no no that's
that's no people most people skip this
part anyway okay
this one for us thanks for reading the
highlights bud let's get into it
[Music]
i fought the unimaginable i've killed
the innocent like snapping their necks
who will save us now
i will and so will others like me
new heroes answering the call have faith
or i will snap your [ __ ] neck
or you'll see me your hope looking at
you with my crazy eyes
but it was the guardians who welcomed me
when i first arrived on this planet
they were my mentors my friends oh
you're an alien threat
i hope they will rest in peace this
could happen to the guardians of the
globe it means that none of us aren't
oh oh it's more blood from last time
because that spot was already there
you pay attention i got four eyes i know
you've always been independent
but i want you to come work for the gda
and build me a new guardians of the
globe
you'll be in charge we just came from
your friend's funeral co-workers
and you're tough
[Music]
know the difference why did he kill
everyone why do you
do this just remember that mark's a 17
year old boy they break more easily he's
clearly not remorseful about it to him
he beat
he beaten tapped he'd be intact he'd be
even
bugged i would never bug this guy
especially across the street
hello hey it's uh
it's mark grace grayson mark grayson
i was thinking finals are coming up and
we're both in miss walker's global
issues class
maybe we can go over everything together
a study date study date
really smooth uh
oh she's aware of the tactics i was
homeschooled
i don't know what they're doing you poor
poor man
i had that call my mom once
this robot man showering i don't know
ever
anything happening is racks around rex
you piece of [ __ ] wait
hang on i knew there was a reason you
skipped the funeral just wait a second
oh god
i can't believe this i thought the same
thing when i was watching her the first
time
[Laughter]
how does that work with her this doesn't
mean [ __ ]
they're not even the real kate we're all
the real cakes
that's technically not what that doesn't
make it better bro
yeah man know how to talk to your
duplicating girls
i have so many questions save them all
for the description
joel haley osmond or whatever i think so
looks like
oh snap
you go eve
[Laughter]
oh look at her she's adorable you're
gonna get yourself isn't there like an
age requirement for this ride
am i wrong this seems weird right okay
what does she do rips i don't know
you're here
isn't there a dick size required oh
we got a little pee pee i mean the way
you've been strutting around here
you must be compensating for something
oh
some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
hell yeah oh damn
did he throw his teeth that's
adorable is this okay he asked for it
jesus yep that's what you get
for being a piece of [ __ ] okay enough
get lost
boy scout i said enough
marcus
you hit that little girl what's going on
guys
no my bad didn't need your help [ __ ]
okay wow i hope you die a terrible
demise
i smell a character arc i can't be on
the same team as
rex and kate hey wait they're mashing
parts
what's going on rex having sex
no regrets whoa
whoa she's upset
rex told her you and me were a thing
what do you mean i just realized his
eyes look like eggs
william said i should read it to show
you that i'm interested
interesting an honest man
i like that it's clearly a cartoon
[Laughter]
seance dog cool you mind if i borrow it
i mean just to show you that i'm
interested
shane afraid okay don't know who that is
sorry must be a robo call
this should do it so miss one
i'm gonna run and use your bathroom
while you deal with that she could just
use the bathroom on command
that's her superpower yeah i gotta pee
whatever i want
whoa christ almighty i didn't think she
would ever leave
are you spying on me oh you want to be a
superhero right
fame glory get the pretty gal don't
worry she hasn't flushed yet how do you
know that
okay yes i want to help rogue super
villain
public in danger he's already enroute
mount rushmore
okay what state is that again what do
they teach you kids in school these days
pound rush forward uh
you know where mount rushmore is
in a state yeah vermont
yeah sure i'll say that vermont yes to
go be spider-man
south dakota he made himself a pair of
earthquake gloves what's he want
oh earthbending he basically gets a
concussion every time he uses him
i don't remember it's a national
treasure down there it's
not going to be a basic deal huh
nicholas cage is on the ground
oh oh is he
going to destroy mount rushmore
somebody get this man a tylenol
because it gets headaches because he
every time he uses this thing
sorry i pay attention
wow man i'm still working on my
one-liners but that one is
really bad that wasn't bad mark
good for you have some confidence man
that was all right that was all right
are you getting there
meta that's how you get ahead
no i liked it you're working on it
you're getting there i liked it
earthquake bracelets you're wearing
earthquake bracelets
quaintlets
what's wrong with earthquake bracelets
it's too long you need to cut the middle
man
they seem pretty effective to me though
i will say yeah he's killing it
but he has the biggest migraine you've
ever seen on my
side
[Music]
that seemed like some anime [ __ ] right
that was cool that was really cool
damn
how cool this show is
oh no [ __ ]
[Music]
oh oh it's clever
just learn it
oh good
oh she got them
oh no
all right his costume's growing on me
he's slipping
yeah god damn it i should have spent
more time working on the jets
what he let himself die
he wanted
of this he let himself die i i'll talk
to you later eve thanks
but what you fly is so cool dude you're
welcome wait she can fly
like i guess i guess she can why why
wasn't she
flying him up when she had him hanging
by the uh
don't question it it didn't look cool
super strength i am so sorry
i've been sitting here for an hour the
whole thing only took an hour why did
you even agree to hang out if you
weren't gonna hang out
i do want to hang out i don't even know
why i came
oh okay then why did you come you didn't
even know i existed until i stood up to
todd
todd kicked your ass for the record
that's
absolutely true
i wanted to know the kind of guy that
would do that
so what now i finished all the review
questions while you were off saving the
world or whatever
she gives me like the boldness of black
cat that's the kind of vibe i'm getting
from her
or like mary jane oh she's moving on the
market and she doesn't go to the funeral
oh oh yeah
wow good for you mark oh love triangles
superheroes just spying on each other
man right
that's messed up that's messed up yeah
what's up with that
steve rogers
child time
you know the drill thursday hey
back oh sheesh
is it more important than we realized i
thought you're just like an opening kind
of villain yeah
stay back from the door
oh huh
[ __ ]
sorry pete oh
oh jesus oh okay that could have been
worse
smack that all on the wall smack that
keep worrying your viewers all right
free us all
smackdown
damn chicken pot pie now you [ __ ] up
how obvious as the original art
[Laughter]
please just open the door say it
stay here forever i'm the clone
yes you are
oh
who the hell are these two exactly they
said it earlier i can't remember the
moeller twins i think
yeah no just like like i thought they'd
be just the
opening villain too yeah oh god
begins again
i mean last time i did take the all the
guardians to take him down
that is true what now
i'm surprised you don't see it you being
the original
you guys are brothers you're happy and
you're singing in your color
give them a high five oh why
i'd say i'll miss you brother
but i can always make another one that's
savage man
oh that is cruel and kind of a cool
story
element thing to include in something
plot thickens my team ready for the deep
end yet
robot but i feel confident in the
progress we've made today
no never never trust a robot
oh man oh that's right
i almost i just almost stopped i forgot
that the show does that crap you got
excited
i was ready to move on with my life
[Laughter]
my husband's a cold-blooded bird
chilling apologies didn't mean to scare
oh what are you doing in my house that
is a metal head
seeking clues that night the massacre
seven dead one alive your
husband was hoping you could make
that piece fit well you'll have to ask
him
did answers were unsatisfactory
he's gonna kill you bro husband told you
nothing
not a whisper to sooth your fears no
he didn't see anything you have a lovely
home
debbie you all right thought i heard
something
he's just under the table i'm fine i was
just coming to bed
i really want him to poke his head
behind the counter oh she must not trust
him either if she's not mentioning
anything about
yeah uh hell constantine oh
no he knows he knows i mean he has been
acting strange lately since the powers
amazon's quick with it i know i don't
give you time to think
we watch the next episode our metadata
shows that people click off if the
credits play we know something but if
you let the next episode play they will
stay continue watching the next hour
play play right away constant constantly
don't show credit
don't show credits to appreciate the
hard work that all these people put into
making this episode
all right so in the in the reality of
when we're watching this episode
the fifth episode's already out we don't
have to talk for too long
okay i set this up every time and then
we talk for 30 minutes and then i gotta
edit it down
what really stands out in this episode
let's try that we did the same thing
when we did umbrella academy all
episodes are released
look lucious talk forever honey all
episodes matter
no i mean that's not to discredit
because i think the reason why i like
breaking it up
is because each episode takes a lot of
work to put together so it's nice to
kind of appreciate it it's a little
isolated piece because it can be easy to
kind of get lost in the binge
and not appreciate the individuality of
each one of these episodes
yeah it gives each episode a room
no it gives every episode of room to
breathe so aaron what was your favorite
thing about this episode
it was the most stand out thing to you
well stand out thing to me uh
that last that last bit we just saw was
really cool you know with uh the mahler
twins
uh let's what i'm trying to remember a
lot happened in this episode i think the
the monster girl overall this wasn't
like i wouldn't say this is the most
exciting episode we've seen in the show
obviously the the first episode
obviously takes the cake with that but i
think it does a great job of
kind of furthering along the plot that
we've kind of established
but to answer your initial question
i think there's a lot there's a lot to
stood out the earthquake stuff
what about you what about you greg let's
go with that
the earthquake stuff was awesome i love
the choreography of all that like i've
been watching avatar
the last airbender and my favorite one
to watch is earthbending out of all the
i don't know if you guys haven't seen
the show but watch on patreon
yeah my favorite one to watch out of all
the bending is is earthbending this is
not exactly the same thing obviously
it's very different in many ways i loved
like a lot of the creativity behind you
know what
i i think this show is i think i finally
figured out what it is it's like a cross
between the boys meets harley quinn
i can see it yeah it has the hard r uh
qualities and and energy of harley quinn
and it's an animated show too like it
like the the animation feels like very
childhood-like
nostalgia feeling and right out of the
comics but it's also very hard-r
and irreverent yeah you know and then
you have like the commentary of the boys
but it's really still
its own like even with that villain the
earthquake villain like he was talking
about like
hey the mountain rushmore people they're
racists they're slave owners
worship me you know he's like making
commentary about eve's costume as well
it still has its own really cool mystery
to it
i appreciate how omni-man is never funny
he's never funny and for some reason i
thought
that he would be kind of a funnier
character no we have not read the comics
so
i thought like with jk simmons being
cast in the role
kind of the symbol that he plays i think
what's so cool about this
is when he is a villain he's a villain
and you know there's something really up
with him
but when he's with his family you really
do feel safe
even though sometimes he can get a
little violent with mark you don't
really feel like he's um
going to harm them you know what i mean
it feels like the one thing he actually
does care about which is like
so that scene on the the stairs when he
was telling him
to take his costume off like after
coming back and and doing the job he's
supposed to do because he
very much feels like the superhero stuff
comes first as opposed to a girl
damn why do i like you right now like
you're you're so genuine and such a good
dad but you are also a
[ __ ] monster yeah it's
it's it makes it like emotionally
conflicting trying to watch him on
screen
and i like the escalating build of what
mark has to deal with
each one of these episodes he does have
kind of a peter parker to boggle not a
hundred percent the same thing
however there it tends to be like an
inner conflict like only
he seems like he's constantly torn
between two choices yeah you know and i
feel like what makes
what impacts our life the most out of
anything is decision
more than conditions this guy's
constantly having to make these tough
calls and these tough decisions and it's
usually involving something where it's a
personal
uh personal inner conflict that he has
something as
primal and a simple like this is
probably the most easy to pinpoint one
of i go on a date with this girl or i go
save
the world you know like which one do i
do and it's cool they explore like the
the relationships they add a little bit
of personality to each character no
one's just like a throwaway line or a
joke
the robot has this moment of identifying
with the monster girl
of i know what it's like to be looked at
only on the outside and not have anyone
try to think what's going on underneath
and i love how that plays as like a
sentimental moment
and like oh he's really compassionate
and then they have the reveal of oh
underneath you're willing to try some
sort of skeevy ass [ __ ] aren't you yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it gives everyone a chance to kind
of stand out even if it is mark's story
everyone gets that chance to to prove
that they're a little bit deeper beyond
the surface which
i think with the amazon show and being
at 45 minutes you do get more of those
chance to let
the entire cast breathe rex even you
know i appreciate that he got a human
moment here
i get a kick out of idiotic like people
who are cocky
when they shouldn't be i love that kind
of humor you're the butt of the joke for
how
egotistical you are you know like i bet
that
whoa dad
dad he's a ghost he's a ghost dad
is your dad dead what he yeah uh
your dad's alive don't tell them they
don't they don't know
about my dad your dad's will smith
don't tell them that damn it everyone
knows
will smith what's the only reason i'm
friends with you i've got over this
i'm trying to get closer to your dad
and jayden you're trying to get my dad
on the channel i know
just for that one video to get some
views and then i'll play fresh prince of
bel air
and it'll get demonetized
and my dad will be in one person
[Laughter]
i'm wondering like which cliches and
conventional stuff they'll be playing
with though okay so take amber who whose
personality i really liked you know she
has that what i call the uh independent
filmmaker girl the zoe de chanel type of
persona you know they're very much
self-aware of the world they inhabit and
they make all the
all the commentary of what's normally
associated in a situation you know what
i'm talking about like
you gotta get zoe additional vibes from
her more like the movies she's been in
which of course right now i can't
remember any of the names of the movie
she's 500 days of summer
kind of yeah that kind of personality
yeah sort of
she's like the you you view her as like
the manic pixie dream girl kind of
well she's not manic uh pixie just slash
manic pixie dream girl she's incredibly
self-aware of every moment the kind of
rom-com she's in in a way
um you know what i mean like she's
pointing out everything ever every step
of the way
right what what's what with mark's
approach her approach
uh everything about his behavior and
that kind of flirty personality and then
you have eve
who actually doesn't go back to rex and
i thought she would go back to rex
yeah but she doesn't and i was like oh
it's cool like
normally i feel like a show would just
be all right i'll give you another
chance you know for the female character
you know what i think it is i think it
does a great job of flirting with
the tropes that we know but then
subverting it just a little bit i
thought amber
with the kind of character she is i was
like why'd she stay the whole time
why'd she stay the whole hour to me i
thought it would have been more
impactful
especially for mark to learn the
consequences for amber to have left
i i can see that i feel like there will
be consequences in the future i don't
think there will be any consequences and
it'll be smooth sailing this would be
just
like spiderman home heavy like damn he
doesn't have a single thing to deal with
there's no i've never seen a show with
no conflict before
god i mean i i i feel like like the
first episode like the darkness is just
it's just creeping around the corner
funny enough i feel like i got like
mj vibes from her like classic mj like
amber i thought i got
because she's black hey i started with
zoey de chanel first i knew you were
gonna pull that [ __ ]
i primed it okay yeah primed it don't
just name a black girl
i meant like in the in the way that she
was like confident you know like
easily saying see her saying like tiger
you just hit the jackpot
comic mj is a lot more um lively like
vibrant like doesn't take [ __ ] from
people
yeah she's like what's with dates like
the star athlete until she realizes
that her neighbor dorky
peters are we breaking down marriages
we do this every time it's not even a
big deal what's going on
it's not even the biggest parts of the
episode
what the woman care grew up this is a
reaction or a podcast
dealing with the i just don't know what
that's what i love about this show so
far i actually don't know what direction
it's going i have no clue where they're
going with mark
um nolan and sandra
who what it is what's her what's her
name what's the mom's name
mom mom omnimo i have no idea what her
name is honestly i have no clue
where where that direction is going um
in terms of what dark things are gonna
happen i have no clue
why nolan i love how the first episode
ends with nolan murdering
uh the guardians we still have no clue
why two episodes later
no clue why and we're building up
everything else around it
primarily mark story and a lot of these
other people who
cannot compete with the powers of omni
man while they're building
all that up and you you get these little
moments where you're like man freaking
omni man is a psychopath
more than they see murders like he can
lie like no other at the funeral and
stuff
yeah most of the episodes of of episode
two and three are not dedicated to omni
man they're dedicated to every
to the other people so it's a cool way
to build him
up i have no clue where the show's going
because it's like wait a minute
yes we're watching the growth of mars
trying to be a superhero that's like the
main plot of him
as invincible and learning about the
world really i'm like what
but the crazy big mysterious plot i have
no
no idea how that's gonna unfold and i
love being in that terrain like i gotta
find out
yeah i feel like so like so far they're
building the mystery of
why omniman is doing there so the or the
mystery of the murder itself
in the background well the mark coming
of age hero stuff is in the foreground
yes and i feel like that's gonna switch
at some point or like those two things
are gonna come to
a head and it's gonna be like the big
clashing of the show by the finale i
know nothing about this i'm just i'm
just
guessing yeah yeah i've heard the comics
are quite different
according to a couple of comments oh
interesting uh
so i have no idea what it's like in the
comics i know amber
is white in the comics and they changed
her to be black woke ass
[ __ ] freaking sjw
and blah blah blah
i almost i'm a cracker poor salt on me
i'm salty
i did hear that mark uh is actually full
white
and his mom is white and in the i think
that's correct
really i don't know with these kind of
things where you can easily get it
ruined for you but
someone know who knows the comics you
try to avoid researching
because it can be very easy for you like
what's probably going to happen next
based on the comics i try not to
research the stuff yeah even
even looking just like up even googling
it is dangerous because you you see
stuff you may not
exactly want to see with google images
yeah i mean i tried finding like the
title for the to do a png for the
thumbnails
and i was like oh wait no this is an
image from the comic i didn't even
realize there was an image for the con i
thought it was from the show i was like
oh damn it's so accurate
i can't read the comment right now
anywho thank you guys for being here why
don't you go ahead subscribe click the
notification
bell hit that like button aaron i
appreciate your presence
hey let's do up
jt jt my man j to the t
for the longest time the entire time
we've had patreon you've been a part of
our patreon page pretty much since the
beginning and you know what's also
really funny you're the
only one i think in the patron of the
day shout outs
who's an asian man the entire time we
have had
our patreon and with that in mind you
know how i deal with you
my asian brother from another mother
which should make you a different
grandmother as well in your lineage
and on top of that you're japanese i'm
filipino
so we're not even related
because i gotta link you to the fact
that there is an asian guy
i'm letting you take this away don't
worry man i've been shouting them out
for
two years i've i've figured out ways to
say it it's cool that we got an asian
representation of a superhero leader
and i gotta say man one day that could
be
you you have helped make me feel
invincible
during times where i felt very much
invincible
that a word snaps sure we'll go with it
i snap snap to it
so it must be it's it's deep and it'd be
racist
if i disagree yes never disagree
[Music]